he might come back to you but the other
woman she could be affected mentally or
physically at 2010 percent happy to go
ahead with it
oh okay
we are now raising funds to build houses
for those who have been homeless due to
natural disasters in Afghanistan Syria
and Pakistan please donate whatever you
can may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
we are back again with a very good video
which is for my content man I don't know
who he is till this day he's on WhatsApp
he sends me these amazing videos they're
all pertaining to Magic and see her and
all that kind of stuff and Gins so this
one again was sent which was very
interesting this is basically a woman
who's calling so basically maybe he had
an advertisement this problem yeah so he
probably has an advertisement yeah we'll
deal with Sahara you know black magic
and this and that so she fought for oh
yeah I said yeah imagine I need that I
need black magic yeah so she calls him
here's the video don't watch it there's
a video of her calling him to get served
down on her husband not knowing that
she's speaking to Iraqi that's mad and
she gets kind of refuted are you ready
no I just need to ask you a few
questions before we go ahead has he
divorced you or not
[Music]
okay one second please one second one
second so he's not divorced you
from home 2001 separated
just separated
because
I want me to divorce them together
somebody said diversion together
passport
okay okay my sister listen to me listen
to me so now is he married to somebody
else
okay listen to me he's with somebody
else now is he here or somewhere else
England or somewhere else
okay which country he's here right now
Bangladesh so you want to bring him back
to you and leave the other woman to
become like before correct
that's perfect does he have children
from The Other Woman
I understand I understand okay listen to
me very careful how many children you
have with him whatever he's done his
life it's nothing to do with me right
now you called me and you asked me if I
can help you to bring your husband back
and that's what we're gonna try to do
okay yeah
so I need to tell you some information
is very important in order for me to do
whatever I am going to do to bring your
husband he's gonna divorce the other one
you're happy with it
you want him to divorce the other one
and to come back to you yeah
okay now remember I understand remember
wherever we are going to do might affect
the other woman another language he
might come back to you but the other
woman she could be affected mentally or
physically at 2010 percent happy to go
ahead with it
oh okay you are happy to go ahead with
the even it harms The Other Woman so I
need from you he's a
one second please our need from you I
need from you to understand if he comes
back to you there's possibility he will
be just listening to you and nobody else
happy with that
but you know what if I'm gonna do is a
class as a spell is Magic you happy to
go ahead with it
right listen to me very carefully listen
to me very careful listen you got my
number from the internet correct
right and you know that I perform or am
healing against black magic you know
that
yeah and you know that by you asking me
to do this to bring your husband it's
not part of my job and it is not
actually what we do we do not do I am
gonna teach you something now as a
Muslim brother ready to hear
fear Allah
stop being stupid
and don't ask anybody to do sir to bring
your husband back and divorce The Other
Woman your call is recorded and you're
gonna go public to teach Muslims what a
woman like you could do your example is
the example of the people that cause say
her to others you separated from him he
married another woman that's his life
that's his decision it shouldn't go to
Black Magic but you are willing to do
anything to bring him fear Allah it's
Haram you go to a magician you try to
bring your husband Allah will judge you
on the day of judgment boy I don't know
do you want to stop we do what we can
that's in our control and that could be
finding the right partner looking at the
right criteria putting ourselves out
there doing this marital kind of
meetings and stuff like that and there
are certain things that are out of our
control I.E the other person saying yes
the other person liking you the other
person staying with you and knowing the
difference between the two is very very
important sometimes people get hooked on
the fact that oh how come this
passengers like me oh well they've left
me what am I gonna do look understand
and distinguish between what's in your
control and your power and what's not in
your control don't become power hungry
realize that that power and control lies
in the hands of Allah and when it comes
to certain things you just have to learn
to let go and stop being egotistical and
stop being somebody that misunderstands
Allah's role in our lives he is the one
that knows everything he is the one that
decides everything we don't control
these things and calling yourself a
Muslim on the one hand and then saying
yeah I'm going to go against Islam use
something that Islam forbids just so I
can get this how on Earth do you think
that something good will come out of
something that you're doing against the
nizam and the third the order of Allah
how and that's why this brother's two
words were very short very sweet Fair
Allah fear Allah stop being stupid like
understand Allah role in your life and
stop feeling like you can do anything
you actually can't without the
permission of Allah exactly you know to
me it's very simple man this is the our
whole problem in this world goes back to
talk and this is the lack of tawakul a
lot of women indulging this I know a
brother who's a dream interpreter
qualified bro I tested my two dreams I
had nothing to do what he told me and I
was like how the hell did he know so
with him bro he said I stopped doing
this because woman became obsessive like
every dream what does this mean it can
go to the point where you know he
stopped it like at one point he said I
stopped it yeah so the reason being is
why because he's like look this turns
into like a fortune telling every dream
I want to know about the future Etc
listen there are reasons why we don't
know it's a blessing from Allah like
they say ignorance is a bliss it is a
blessing from Allah that you don't know
what the future holds if you knew what
the future holds arguments like if I
knew 10 years down the line something
very bad is going to happen to someone
if I know it now I'm going to be
depressed about it yeah yeah and when
I'm in this moment I can't deal with it
but when I'm there maybe Allah is
preparing me that when that happens I'm
ready but I didn't know about it so the
thing is this is called tawakul having
trust
to break up the marriage
this is very interesting and what is she
doing is no fear to the other person and
like Allah says in the Quran and Surah
Yusuf that the wrongdoers will never be
successful meaning anyone that indulges
in Haram to this level of said hey this
is this is this is Coffer this is the
verge of you can become a disbeliever
yeah you are doing nothing but putting
Minds in front of you when Allah says
that the evil doers will never be
successful it means the actions the sins
that you do towards against Allah and
other people you are only sabotaging
your and the blessings that could come
you only sabotaging that why because of
something happened that you didn't like
this is why we believe in the good and
the bad if it happens and may Allah not
test us and make us firm in this
inshallah is what whatever happens we
put our trust in Allah we have trust in
Allah not read this tarot cards go to a
fortune teller Etc no don't the
curiosity killed the cat so we're saying
brothers and sisters that be very
careful this is a mercy from Allah that
she ended up calling Iraqi that at least
she got something like Allah says in the
Quran we send a small Calamity because
this was an embarrassing Calamity and if
you think about it today divert a bigger
Calamity which is a Hellfire you're
going to do sir you are lucky you call
that bike the Qatar of Allah you called
it that he put some sense into you
whoever the hell you are yeah fear Allah
don't go to these people because believe
me all you're doing is losing your hair
after and let this be a lesson like the
brother said alhamdulillah that fear
Allah brothers and sisters
straight maybe Allah will send you a
better husband although sin the husband
is bad but the point is what look it
shows what kind of a woman you are maybe
that guy's bloody right for bloody uh
leaving you I'm so sorry there's a good
point
to say that you know what we shouldn't
be erratic we shouldn't be impatient
yeah and sometimes yeah don't be
impulsive that's the word don't be
impulsive in relationships because
you're gonna be like this woman trying
to clutch straws even going into Haram
ruining your hair after and if that guy
comes back he's clearly not gonna be
good for you so rather than regretting
it afterwards because regret is one of
the things that it's very difficult for
us to digest so if you are in a
relationship make sure you're you're in
it okay you're in it 100 yeah give it
your time give it your energy and if
things go wrong go to the right people
go to mediators go to counselors you
know watch these couples counseling
videos if you can't go buy books
exchange ideas invest yeah do your best
Allah will do the rest then if it's not
meant to be it's not meant to be but
people just oh this happened I'm just
gonna go and this and that the impulsive
nature of our society is actually
killing us and not only killing us
because normally when you die you just
remove from the world but it's killing
your hair after now as well which is
that you yeah which is worse yeah so
you're ruining your world and in
Hereafter because of impulse that's all
it is exactly and ask Allah if this man
is good for me returning back to me if
he's not then don't have that trust in
Allah and you know what maybe Allah may
have returned your husband back to you
if you was patient argument's sake do
you get it but now you're going to
foreign
[Music]